souvenez-vous radio baba 2017 oui
aujourd'hui le président de
l'association le refuge nicolas noguier
a fait un communiqué de presse très
important dans ce communiqué il revient
sur le témoignage du jeune homme de
l'association qui faisait suite au
canular et regardez ce que dit ce
communiqué c'est juste je les ai vus
attendu oui et c'est vrai j'avais vu
alors on lire
donc c'est vrai que voilà on mai 2010
est à la suite de l'émission backline
diffusée sur s'est vite j'avais indiqué
qu'un jeune homme avait contacté
l'association le refuge à plusieurs
reprises car il avait été reconnu par
ses parents qui découvre son
homosexualité avait chassés de chez eux
or il est apparu depuis lors qu'un site
ainsi que mon avocat l'a indiqué à la
presse que ces appels avaient été
imaginées par un bénévole de
l'association et ceux de sa seule
initiative des sanctions appropriées ont
été prises par l'association le refuge à
l'encontre de ce bénévole qui n'exerce
plus au sein de l'association et dont le
comportement a été l'origine d'un
préjudice important pour l'association
ela lutte contre l'homophobie cause
qu'elle défend depuis de nombreuses
années je regrette également les
conséquences de cet effet que cet
événement a eu pour cyril hanouna et c8
et présente toutes mes excuses pour les
désagréments rencontrés nous savons que
nous pourrons bénéficier comme par le
passé du soutien de cyril hanouna et ses
huit courses ou poursuivre la lutte
contre l'homophobie et les en remercie
incroyable qui présente ses excuses
parce que c'était un moment assez grave
c'est bien de sa part et on continuera à
aider le refuge comme on l'a on l'a
toujours fait une grande trahison font
raser mission pour février non mais des
moments épouvantable parce que dans la
presse on a vraiment été mais montrer du
doigt par tous moi je me souviens de
notre équipe à cannes
dix ans le furoncle en une hanouna et
ses sbires les sbires c'était nous donc
moi je trouve franchement on hamon a
lourdement payé pour une fois qu'on
savait ne pas avoir commise oui il
faudrait que tous les médias qui avaient
abondamment relayé l'information est
vraie ouais relais ce communiqué alors
soit bien commencé il ya un lien vers ce
roe sur aude hérault qui a repris avec
jean marc morandini est tout à fait
improbable arts sciences qui avait été
fait à l'époque ça c'est sûr non tu vas
tu journalistes à berlin ila dessus et
aussi parfois moi je suis journaliste
on a le droit de s'excuser quand ils ont
créé voilà qu'ils veulent c'est quelque
chose qui soude et des conséquences pour
vous parce que on se connaît un peu et
on n'a pas aidé les gens savent pas quel
point ça vous a blessé ça vous avorter à
l'étranger à arrêter la télé et moi le
linge si ça peut ça ça me rend fou et
dans ce cas précis c'est très bien
qu'ils aient des excuses mais une
injustice par des conséquences
dramatiques et en a eu vous n'êtes pas
forcément mais simple en avoir sur les
gens comme comme vous serrez voilà donc
on voulait plutôt bien voilà en tout cas
merci christine d'en avoir parlé